hey peeps uh it's not looking like it's
gonna happen tonight does the president
know why we're here
don't look up was a tragically funny
movie that we still can't help but think
about now we're going behind the scenes
to bring you the best improvised moments
from the movie check it out ariana
grande can definitely improvise number
one what's more impressive than improv
improving in a song ariana grande's best
improv moment was when she sang the song
for the first time her first take blew
director adam mckay away because she
came up with these lyrics on the spot
turn off fox news cause you're about to
die actually she came up with that whole
bit grande was hired to sing director
adam mckay had no idea about her ability
to improv like that so you can imagine
it was an exciting moment also is it
weird that we're totally obsessed and
can't stop listening to the song number
2. childhood ruined tyler perry was
called one of the biggest improvisers in
the movie and those scenes at the daily
rip were chalked full of improvised
quips between his character jack and
co-host brie played by kate blanchett
just a couple of the lines they
ad-libbed were i had no idea that subaru
made telescopes and a cute little back
and forth about xanax listen if you
don't have enough we all have enough
around here which she responded with a
spoon full of xanax makes the medicine
go down that's right number three can
this be added to the blu-rays bonus
content meryl streep improvised 30
different phone calls that she had to
hang up on associate producer stacy
roberts said every single one of them
started off with something like no i had
implants i got them taken out and at the
end said i love you goodbye sadly all
that work was for nothing because the
bit didn't make it past the cutting room
floor number four nobody knows what this
thing is there was an earlier improv in
the movie that set up the mid-credits
fate of the president she's told by elon
musk ah we mean peter that she'll be
eaten by a brontorack we don't know what
it means they were shooting the scene
for the second launch in the bash
control room when the director proposed
that they improvised merrell in
character said it got me so excited to
know about my own death i want to know
every time they improved it the name of
the creature changed a what well it
influenced the mid-credits scene which
had to be re-filmed originally the
characters realized that the pod
carrying the workers blew up so they all
tried to pay each other to build them a
house
number five cruel jason cruel jonah hale
is such a comedic master that we one
time dedicated an entire day to him just
improving insults at me are you
surprised it was amazing it was really
really hard filming with jonah because
he made it his mission to make her crack
one of the lines which really is
downright cruel came right after kate
found out the president had decided to
do something about the comet he
said he just looks so bad
but make no mistake jonah did not like
insulting j-law he's a teddy bear number
six is an adult ability to play pretend
or a child's ability more impressive the
sesame street bit where leonardo
dicaprio gets honest about the fate of
the world and yells at the camera
improvised and the little child crying i
don't like him he makes me sad i'm sorry
about that also improvised good on you
kid for keeping up with the a-listers
number seven stuff glorious stuff we can
never have enough stuff jonah hill's
character jason's whole prayer for stuff
was totally improvised if you couldn't
tell sure stuff is cool there's dope
stuff but you know what's cooler than
stuff
existing oh man
number eight the completely
inappropriate fist bump jonah's line
thanks for dressing up was another
comedy gold moment from the guy just
imagine meeting the president's son and
you're greeted with a fist bump number
nine one of the weirdest lines in the
movie came from a character without a
name
a friend of timote chalamet's character
yuel can i touch her hair in a
non-sexual way totally improvised
totally awkward but to be honest it's
some awesome looking hair jlaw picked it
out herself despite knowing most people
hate the look of the short bangs hideous
as it may be to some people i was just
like oh there she is and she's right it
totally works for the character and hey
at least the guy asked before he touched
it number 10. the best kind of potatoes
dicaprio's original line was about sweet
potatoes instead they all partook in a
little improv about searching for
fingerling potatoes but the best line of
the little bit definitely came from
chalamet fingerling
i love fingerling potatoes it's number
11 the place that inspires the most
amount of improvisation in the world
the first scene in the oval office took
two days to shoot the first cut of the
scene was a whopping 16 minutes long and
the director never once got bored of
watching it unfortunately when it was
that long that early in the movie it
slowed the plot to a near stop a couple
of lines that made it in the scene were
you're breathing weird it's uh it's
making me uncomfortable
and
i can't think of another president that
i'd ever want to see in playboy number
12 this strays pretty far from the
beaten path from here to the end these
were all sourced directly from a
comparison between the final script and
the movie it was pretty tough to follow
along with the actors improvising so
much the lines where kate was chatting
with her boyfriend over the phone went
so far off the rails he says do you have
an issue with my mom is that what this
is all about he gets cut off but when it
comes back around says she asked you if
you were a lesbian she did not say that
you were a lesbian this set up the
beautiful response from jennifer
lawrence look i can i sit down with your
mom to have lunch and like seven months
we don't think it's necessary to say why
this weirdly specific and distant
comment is hilarious number 13. when you
meet a superstar what's your first
thought dicaprio's quip she looks a lot
smaller in person doesn't she
about riley bena was totally of his own
observance we wonder if that was his
actual first thought when he met ariana
grande sometimes observational humor
just can't be written into a script you
need to see it to think it number 14.
nobody knows randall like leo knows
randall and randall doesn't understand
memes or how to comfort women all of
dicaprio's reassurances towards kate
becoming a meme were improvised here's
the lines i mean look at that
that's so unnecessary and
is that even allowed on the internet or
i think that's photoshop
number 15. he was totally chosen to go
to space because of his astronomically
good looks
we're gonna need a hero
we're gonna need a pilot
ron pearlman's got a great body or at
least his character benedict drask does
so says the president and dr calder dr
calder admits you know i used to date
him that was totally improvised and so
was the banter he's got a great body too
he does he really does yeah number 16.
the door slam in this scene was made
even better what if we have to go to the
bathroom
her question was supposed to be left
unanswered instead we got the awesome
bit where jonah as jason says we'll lay
out some newspaper for you grab you a
can of a breeze and also his devious bit
of false hope where he asks you want to
come yeah boom door slam
and just to end things off while we
aren't positive if this was improvised
or just a last minute edition we wanted
to include it anyway initially the last
line is a simple conversation about
grinding coffee i grind my own beans
yeah which is still there but we also
get dicaprio saying we really did have
everything didn't we that one was
chilling and a good note to leave off on
be grateful for what you have but more
importantly take care of it what part of
don't look up made you laugh the most
let us know in the comments and thanks
for watching